hi everyone it is seven o'clock you are
very welcome to join us on the breakfast
show here on Sky News Monday morning
wherever you're watching us rise around
the world the Home Secretary has called
the Asylum system broken swella Braven
will hope a new migration deal shall
side with France this morning we'll help
fix it but will it be enough to stop
people making the perilous journey
across the channel join shortly by the
foreign secretary that's James cleverley
of course also on the program the mayor
of London City Khan the former UK
ambassador to France the Peter West
McCart and the former director general
of the UK border Force Tony Smith and
we'll be live throughout the morning on
both sides of the channel it is Monday
the 14th of November
are pact with Paris the Home Secretary
to sign a deal with France this morning
to tackle Channel Crossings as
traffickers turn to more dangerous
methods
it comes after a sharp rise in the
number of people reaching these Shores
in small boats I'll be live here in
Dover
we'll have the latest from Calais where
migrant boats continue to attempt the
dangerous Crossing
calling out Putin's regime which she
soon act says he'll confront Russia's
foreign minister as the PM heads to a
meeting of the world's biggest economies
Joe Biden will hold a high-stakes
meeting with China's president Xi
Jinping ahead of the G20 Summit it's the
first time the leaders have met in
person since Biden became president
Ukraine's president accuses Russian
soldiers of committing war crimes and
killing civilians in cursong as
residents take stock after the city was
liberated
whilst ahead we'll speak to the man who
built himself in an arm out of Lego
after years of hiding is missingly
foreigners with us this morning ladies
and gentlemen good morning wherever
you're watching us um are you a Taylor
Swift fan I do like a bit of Taylor
Swift you looked as though you would
yeah I do like a bit of Taylor Swift at
the karaoke I think it suits my Persona
okay what's your favorite song
uh we are never ever getting back I knew
you would say that as well I suppose you
could sing that to Liz trust couldn't
you uh no tell me about this deal
well look
um we have got to get a grip of the
international trade in uh in in human
misery these people traffickers who are
putting lives at risk by facilitating
the illegal Crossing of migrants into
the UK and around the world we've got to
get a grip of that and we've got to do
that with Partners that's why I was part
of the reason why I was in France last
week speaking with my opposite number
and the reason that the Home Secretary
is speaking with her opposite number in
France because we do need to work with
our International Partners including
France and including the countries from
which these people come
break the business model of these people
traffickers and to prevent these illegal
Crossings into the UK
from previous deals
well we need to always adapt and update
we we see that these people traffickers
constantly changing their tactics the
way they use technology how they try and
evade law enforcement so it's important
that we that we speak with our
International friends and allies about
updating our uh our procedures but also
of course we need to make sure that
these these these deals these
Arrangements these agreements continue
and that's what the that's what the home
sex will be doing so is there any major
difference between this deal and the
ones that pretty Patel did and the the
one that would that cost us tens of
millions that had been done previously
as well and also the Le 2K agreement so
those deals have been effective they've
not completely stopped The Crossings but
for example uh France has stopped 29
000 29 000 illegal Crossings that's
twice the number that they stopped in
the previous year these are significant
numbers sadly unfortunately there are
still significant numbers of people
crossing the channel so we've got to
work on that we've also got to work on
repatriating them back to their
countries quickly but these agreements
do have an effect they are not the
complete solution we have to as I say
work with the countries from which these
people come the countries that they're
traveling through and also of course we
need to make sure that our legal
processes are fast effective fair but
also are understood that that we will
repatriate people we will send people
back if they don't have a legitimate
reason to be here so the 80 million quid
that we're going to give to France for
this latest deal uh what sort of numbers
would you like to see reduced by the
French side in order for it to have been
worth the money well look these are the
things that the Home Secretary will be
discussing with her opposite numbers but
we want of course uh last week as I say
I was speaking with the French uh
foreign
so it wasn't it's it's not part of my uh
part of the process to come up with the
specific numbers that's for the Home
Secretary and her counterpart but the
French of course understand how
important this is they don't want to see
these people on their Beaches they don't
want to see these criminal gangs
operating in their country and we've
made with the cooperation of
international Partners we've made over
500 arrests of these people traffickers
we've broken over 50 criminal gangs this
is what we do by working yes exactly
it's what we do we work together so
there's still more work and you also
trumped the 29 000 so what I'm saying to
you is for the 80 million quid that it's
going to cost us what do you want to see
as a result well the numbers the numbers
are well ultimately what we want to see
is these uh uh these these Crossings
reduced completely but we have to be we
have to be realistic that the the people
traffickers are working incredibly hard
to try and so we don't have any law
enforcement okay we need to work just as
hard to counter their illegal activities
we wanted the Brits wanted to be part of
the patrols to try to stop the crossings
that was one of the sticking points and
the French wouldn't let us how do you
feel about that well we have got to make
sure that we uh understand the
respective jurisdictions we need to make
sure that our law enforcement officials
are working as effectively as possible
the details of the agreement that will
be thrashed out between their home
sector and the French interior Minister
um the important thing is that we work
closely the important thing is that
we're sharing information the important
thing is we are gripping the people
traffickers and preventing their uh evil
business that is exactly how we do that
that will be done that will be agreed
through negotiations but the important
thing is that we are and we will
continue to work very very closely the
other thing is I mean the last two deals
I'm just looking at the numbers pretty
Patel 54 million pounds before that
November 2020 28 million pound deal they
haven't been successful because we're
seeing them coming over migrants coming
over whether you call them a league or
not in in in record numbers so well look
they've not been they've not spit no one
thing provides the complete answer to
this and that's why that's why as I say
we've got to deal with the the situation
the countries where these people come
from whether it's whether they're
fleeing economic circumstances or War or
conflict we need to try and make the
countries that they're coming from
better so there's less incentive for
them to leave we have to make sure we
work with our International partners and
as I say the the deals that as well as
predecessor put in place have had an
effect they have not completely stopped
it and that sadly is why we're still
seeing uh people crossing on small boats
but they have had an effect they have
broken a number of these criminal gangs
they have prevented uh tens of thousands
of people crossing the channel and they
have broken a significa a significant
number
record numbers but indeed and we are not
going to rest we are not going to rest
until we get a resolution on this and
and the the arrangement that we're
making with friends is incredibly
important
um and it's part of an overall mix
um we want our border force to be on uh
French territory which is what we've
agreed but apparently the Border Force
are going on strike so what does that
lead to do
well I think it is uh look we we all
recognize that public servants are under
uh pressure because of the economic
situation we're seeing right across the
globe and we we absolutely recognize
that but ultimately there is a really
important job to do the uh the Border
Force officials play an important part
of keeping our country safe
um I would uh I would want them to be
focused exclusively on that and they
have to recognize that this is a a very
difficult
economic situation right across the
globe I understand but what does it
leave the deal if they're on strike well
as I say we will uh we will I have no
doubt work with the representative
bodies of the Border force uh to uh to
encourage them to stay focused on the
job in hand but ultimately
at a minister level we will be
negotiating with our friends and allies
around the world to put Arrangements in
place to protect the wrong strike to
protect ourselves from these legal
migrations okay um data released to the
refugee Council by their home office 122
206 migrants waiting to have their
claims assessed 725 have been waiting
for more than five years isn't that
where we should be investing the money
well we do have to speed up the uh the
the the processing of uh uh claims and
there are there are improvements that
we've driven through the uh through the
recent legislation we took through the
house legislation that was opposed by
the labor party to prevent things like
multiple claims which massively
massively slow down the system to ensure
that the processing of migrants can be
done fairly but fast that's better for
everybody it's better for them so they
know what their status is it's better
for the UK because it cost us less money
and we can resolve these issues and so
the uh so the legislation that we have
recently put in place will go a long way
to addressing those long delays which
are not good for anyone they're not good
for the microbes themselves they're
certainly not good for the UK I was
looking for um ways to try to save money
or invest money in order to make things
better for migrants ETC and we've been
hearing from the immigration Minister
and he has said weirdly he said Robert
generic that those coming should be
given simple functional accommodation
that does not create an additional pull
factor for one second do you think that
people are fleeing the situation in
Afghanistan so they can stay in a
Premier Inn Andover well we do know so
the Afghans that supported us whilst we
were in Afghanistan we we do have a duty
to them and we are absolutely supporting
them and that's why we have supported a
significant number coming to the UK
however but this directly to your
question however there are definitely
people coming to the UK not because they
are fleeing persecution because they are
seeking economically a better life now I
completely get that the UK is a great
place to live and work and it is
unsurprising that people around the
world want to come here but we we know
there's there's video footage there are
people
they are there are people posting onto
social media the fact that they are
really happy that they are coming to the
UK that they've got to the UK seeking a
better economic life not fleeing
persecution seeking a better economics
that is that is that is very very
different to the people fleeing uh
some people are definitely motivated to
come to the UK because they feel this is
a nicer and better place to live and
work than where they currently live they
are economic migrants and it's really
really important and we have this uh
discussion about illicit immigration
there are some people like the Hong Kong
like the Hong kongers like the
ukrainians like the Afghans who are
fleeing war or persecution there are
others who are economic migrants we we
really need to recognize and some of
those economic migrants put themselves
in the hands of people traffickers but
we have to recognize there is a
difference how many do you think will
finally send to Rwanda
well I I I don't know I I don't know
what we do no no we are uh we're going
through legal processes to uh to get
those flights
but we will continue to put forward
plans to break the economic model of the
people traffickers the message we need
to send to the people who put their
lives and money in the hands of people
traffickers is it is a waste it's a
waste it's still coming but we have to
make 120 million we have to make sure
that people recognize that it is a waste
of money
to to pay people traffickers to get to
the UK because they will be repatriated
and finally we're almost out of time the
boss has been um criticizing Putin in
one of the papers this morning for not
going along to the G20 Summit if he
changed his mind and he did go
would our prime minister sit down with
him well we will confront Russia about
their behavior we're not going to so
we're what we're not going to do is
we're not going to normalize the
relationship we're not going to
normalize relationship with Russia
because Russia has invaded its neighbor
it has breached the U.N chart you can't
criticize him for not going and then not
sit down we will absolutely as we do
when I was at the United Nations uh a
little earlier on this Autumn I sat in
the same room as Sergey lavrov I
criticized the Russian invasion of
Ukraine I stood in solidarity
International uh colleagues and Friends
if at whatever level Russia is
represented at the G20 the Prime
Minister will absolutely call them out
absolutely confronted with their Elite
for their illegal unprovoked invasion of
Ukraine what do you sit down with
okay I'm not going and then you're
you're trying to make a I mean you're
trying to make a I don't know a question
out of something which for me is a
really really straightforward we will
confront them we are not going to
normalize them we are not going to act
with them as we would do with our our
friends and allies at the G20 that is we
are not going to normalize the
relationship in light of the appalling
uh uh activity
that we've seen Russia conducting we
will absolutely confront them we will
absolutely call them out good to see you
as always thank you very much indeed
thank you let's look at the papers for
you this morning starting with the times
the time covering that new pack with
France aiming to stem record numbers of
migrants crossing the channel uh the
telegraph reports that Rishi sunak has
told G20 leaders that Russia is a rogue
State the express leads with the
Chancellor's warning of choppy Waters
ahead as he announced we'll be paying
more tax following his Autumn statement
tax Rises for all and energy help just
for the poorest who is the front of the
eye
Guardian reports that up to a third of
England's hospital beds are filled with
patients well enough to be discharged
but with no suitable place to go
and the mirror says it's the last chance
to save the NHS as unions warn the
service is on the brink of collapse
more on the migrant crisis for you know
either standing by in Dover for us this
morning I have a very good morning to
you
um the foreign secretary dodging quite a
few of my questions when it came to why
migrants were coming over uh the channel
what is the situation there this morning
yeah that's right okay good morning and
so here in David this is where migrants
are first brought when they arrive um in
Britain after crossing the channel it's
quiet here in the at the moment but we
expected to get busier because it is
quite favorable for conditions for
Crossings and of course for the as a
whole it's never been busier here
um nearly a thousand people arrived here
on Saturday alone and for the year as a
whole already more than 40 000 migrants
have made the dangerous Crossing across
the channel and that is despite the
government already unveiling this big
plan the Rwanda plan that you mentioned
six months ago that the government said
would deter people making this dangerous
crossing that's plainly not been the
case and as you heard from the foreign
secretary there it now has this problem
that it can't keep up the government
can't keep up with the number of Asylum
claims that need to be processed it
means thousands are having to wait years
in the kind of legal limbo all the while
being housed in hotels that's costing
the government the UK taxpayer nearly
seven million pounds a day and as we've
seen recently the government is now
struggling to book hotels fast enough to
to keep up with the number of arrivals
which is in turn prompting this backlog
of people this over capacity at the
temporary processing places centers both
here in Dover and at manston that's it's
also leading to outbreaks of disease
diphtheria there are all sorts of
problems now the system has been
described by the Home Secretary herself
as broken this deal is the government's
latest attempt to fix it
okay but no thanks so much indeed over
thank you
I still come on the program for you this
morning speaking to former UK ambassador
to France and the U.S a Peter Westcott
ahead of the G20 Summit as well as that
migrant deal with Paris
joined by the mayor of London City Khan
[Music]
and speaking to the Royal editor and
author Robert jobson about the king's
appearance at the remembrance Sunday
service birthday today
has promised to call out Russia's regime
in person today as he faces Russian
foreign minister Sergey lavrov at the
G20 Summit in Bali first time a British
prime minister hasn't met with anyone
from Putin's Administration since the
start of the war in Ukraine also
attending the G20 Summit are the U.S
President Joe Biden and China Xi Jinping
who will sit down for their first
in-person meeting later on today what
might it look like let's find out Helena
standing by for us hello Helena very
good morning
good morning Kay yes as you say the G20
officially kicking off tomorrow but
today all eyes will really be on this
meeting between President Biden of the
United States and president Xi Jinping
of China the two men will sit down for
the first time since President Biden
became president they have had a number
of phone and video calls after over the
two years that he's been in office but
this is the first time they will have
met face to face and it's no
exaggeration to say that they meet at a
time of seriously declining relations
between the two countries there are many
experts that say the relations between
the US and China are perhaps the worst
they've been since as far ago as the 70s
or 80s there are a swathe of issues that
divide them from Hong Kong to Taiwan to
tensions on the Korean Peninsula to
trade the list goes on and on and many
of those things will come up certainly
the Euro the war in Ukraine will come up
in that meeting today I think there's a
bit of a cautious sort of pessimism on
both sides really I don't think anyone
expects any any great breakthrough to
come from this meeting but certainly the
Americans have been briefing the press
this morning that the aim is really to
just try and steady relations between
the two countries to try and put what
they're calling a flaw on this
deterioration of relations to try and
make a sort of mutual understanding that
the communication channel should remain
open between those two countries and
that any sense that the competition that
exists between them if that ever were to
Veer into a conflict would be disastrous
for not just those two countries but for
the world I think it's important to
stress that the Chinese probably feel
quite similar in terms of their approach
here a lot of quiet diplomacy will have
gone on from both sides in order to
allow this meeting to happen in the
first place and a lot of gestures of
quiet Goodwill in sort of diplomatic
senses on both sides so I think there is
a lot at stake but I think the fact that
it's even happening is certainly
significant okay thank you excuse me the
Ukrainian President says investigators
have uncovered more than 400 war crimes
in newly liberated regions of coastal
after Saturday's jubilant scenes of
Celebration and an outpouring of emotion
in the city residents are now taking
stock of the extensive damage left
behind by the kremlin's retreating
forces many is still coming to terms
with the eight months spent under
Russian occupation here's our
International correspondent Alex Rossi
he's been listening to the stories of
the people of coastal
thank you
this is the first time Valerie's been
back to the prison where the Russians
took him
is a successful businessman and was
arrested when he resisted after soldiers
stole his trucks from his Factory but
what the Russians didn't know was their
crimes were recorded on CCTV as they
looted his office and drove away his
Vehicles he shows me the images on his
phone
14th of March yeah
each one is dated It All Happened
shortly after they invaded Kirsten City
smashed up the computers
on the walls of the prison graffiti
reads zelenski we are coming
Valeri considers himself lucky as other
inmates were tortured far worse
foreign
[Music]
foreign
the pain of the Russian occupation is
everywhere this is a city still coming
to terms and dealing with a collective
trauma
there are still people out celebrating
but much of the Euphoria has given way
to something else and that is the
Practical reality of surviving in a city
where everything is in short supply now
when the Russians left they destroyed
much of the infrastructure and the local
authorities here are saying that this
place is now facing a humanitarian
catastrophe
every day the cues for water get longer
a miserable weight in the biting cold
power two is hard to come by people
crowd around a generator to charge their
phones and torches
amongst them is Lisa who's been waiting
here for the last three hours it's
becoming part of her daily routine but
she's apprehensive
foreign
you can of course still feel the
intoxicating atmosphere of liberation
but people are weary and they're fearful
of what comes next Alex Rossi Sky News
Quezon City
for making news for you this morning 22
people detained including the person
believed to have planted the bomb uh
here in Istanbul Turkish interior
Minister blame Kurdish militants for the
blast which kills six people and injured
another 81. the target was one of the
city's busiest shopping streets popular
with tourists
Boris Becker has signed up for a
fast-track prison release scheme that
would seem deported to Germany according
to reports the disgraced former tennis
star could walk free in December in time
for Christmas just eight months after
being sentenced to two and a half years
behind bars
the 54 year old convicted in April of
breaching insolvency Rules by hiding two
and a half million pounds in cash shares
and property
militia celebrations are taking place in
London today to Mark King Charles's
birthday a performance of happy birthday
by the band of the household Cavalry and
a 41-gun royal salute are among events
scheduled for the king turning 74.
still to come speaking to the mayor of
London City Khan about the cost of
living crisis and spiraling renting
costs ahead of the Chancellor's Autumn
statement
[Music]
hello again everybody very welcome to
join us on the breakfast show here on
Sky News Monday morning as you can see
she's here at this Adele afoot very soon
probably about eight o'clock didn't get
much from the foreign secretary did we
well yes this deal I think we're gonna
see sowella Bravo in the Home Secretary
pop-up in France uh in the next hour to
say that a deal has been sealed with the
French government about migration I
think what struck me really is remember
pretty Patel signing a deal with the
French last summer and at the time she
and the French interior Minister were
talking about clamping down and migrant
Crossing stopping a hundred percent of
them I think they said there's no such
rhetoric this time everybody knows that
this is going to be one part of it and
the government hope it will make a
difference but it's not going to make an
enormous difference because it is such a
difficult issue so they're hoping
they're having for the first time
British border Force inside the French
control rooms and of course French for
the force therefore inside the British
ones as well will make a difference to
how many boats they managed to invest
that before they set sail and we also
know that they're investing heavily in
new technology it's expected that this
deal will cost over 60 million pounds to
the British government that's a bit more
than the 55 million we pay the French
last year so it is a diplomatic success
for Richie sunac and for the Home
Secretary that this has come off after
months of work the French stopped as
Government ministers quite often tell us
29 000 Crossings this year can they
increase that dramatically in order to
lower the numbers next year is the real
question yeah and actually put to James
cleverly we've given the French hundreds
of millions in the past with varying
deals including the one you just
mentioned so what's different this time
we have got to get a grip of the
international trade in uh in in human
misery these people traffickers who are
putting lives at risk we need to always
adapt and update uh we we see that these
people traffickers constantly changing
their tactics the way they use
technology how they try and evade law
enforcement so it's important that we uh
that we speak with our International
friends and allies about updating our uh
our our procedures
so he says that there are new tactics
therefore we need new deals to tackle
them but she seen that knows that he's
got maximum of two years until the next
election and this is an issue of great
interest to voters and to conservative
MPS he was telling reporters on the
plane to Bali where he's on the way to
the G20 Summit that he spent more time
on this than on the Autumn statement
because he's so concerned to get this
right but of course the key question is
results and the other issue is that the
number of people waiting for an asylum
decision once they get here is now
fallen dramatically and the government
don't seem to have a coherent plan to
get it up again okay for now tomorrow
thanks very much indeed uh also joining
us is our Europe correspondent Adam
Parsons who witnessed people trying to
make the dangerous Channel Crossing from
Calais yesterday
um hi Adam talk to us about what happens
when they try and get on these boats
well this is uh blerio Plage on the
North French coast and what the team
filmed yesterday uh were people who who
ran all the way pretty much from this
point down uh towards the sea but then
got involved in this kind of Catch Me
game with the authorities police
officers who were also stationed on the
beach now the reason that they were just
trying to get into the scene is because
of a new tactic that we're seeing pretty
much for the first time which is people
Smugglers out there in the channel in
smaller boats who are acting as as taxi
services effectively and the uh the
people trying to get down the beach the
the migrants evade the police and then
once they are in the sea then the French
police have kind of Rules of Engagement
which say they don't go into the sea so
once you are in the sea you then clamber
on board one of these uh these dinghies
and then that is the start of your uh
your journey over to the British Coast
what we have previously seen are people
coming down from genes like this
carrying boats towards the sea now this
is this is slightly but I think quite
importantly different just the people
trying to get in the water now of course
this is this is highly precarious these
boats become overloaded they often are
using Motors that are just simply not up
to the job and what we saw were people
being effectively jettisoned from these
boats in order to make them that much
lighter so they can get across I think a
few other things to take away it used to
be that at this time of year as you're
headed towards winter the number of
Crossings really declined we aren't
seeing that at the moment on Saturday
972 people were counted as having
crossed the channel and and what you are
seeing in recent times is an absolute
explosion in the number of cross Channel
attempts uh to get from from here into
Britain now that could be because of uh
preponderance of wars of course in Syria
in Afghanistan and Russian in other
places it could be that actually that's
a result of people no longer really
being able to get across on the back of
lorries that used to be the route of
choice now it's uh it's boats and the
other thing I would say is we have had a
succession of meetings between French
and British governments heralding new
deals that will cope with the so-called
migrant crisis so far none of them have
actually made a profound difference I
think there's a lot of weight on this
one
okay thank you well joining us now
um former British ambassador to the U.S
France and turkey that's to Peter West
McCart um hi sir Peter thanks for
joining us I mean just looking at when
you were the former ambassador to France
that was in the early days of the Le 2K
agreement of course
um how far have we come since then
well I was there for five years between
2007 2012. so the 2K was was up and
running and it's sometimes easy to
forget that ever since that agreement
we've had about a thousand British
officials operating on French territory
controlling migration Manning the
passport booze uh looking at the
passports and so on different of course
from what we're talking about now which
is police patrols along the beaches but
there has been quite a lot of
cooperation with the French over the
years and then there was what they
called The Jungle which was the really
very messy Camp which disrupted people's
lives around Calais which was demolished
some years back what's happened since
then I think is that it went quieter and
now it's picked up again right now we've
got a very mild Autumn uh the sea is not
as rough as you might expect in November
temperatures are a little bit higher and
very Lots Big increase in organized
criminal gangs trying to get people
across so I'm afraid the fundamental
problem hasn't gone away lots of people
want him to come to Britain either as
economic migrants or or fleeing conflict
or starvation or whatever in other parts
of the world and there is a magnetic
effect there's no doubt about it people
want to come to Britain even though
we're not very efficient at processing
their Asylum applications indeed so as I
Illustrated to the foreign secretary in
a little bit earlier on this hour
but do from when you were there
um what impression did you get about how
hard the French were trying to stop
people getting into these boats and
risking their lives to come across the
channel
you know it's a very long coastline and
it's a very long very pretty beach all
the way along the channel
um there were always a few hundred uh
French policemen there some of them was
on occasion photographed standing around
doing not much in the Years Gone by but
I think I'm writing and saying that for
all the talk of the 60 70 million pounds
that we're giving uh now each year to
the French government they are spending
250 million pounds of their own money on
policing the coast
um on their side of the channel opposite
the United Kingdom so they have put
quite a lot of resource into it but I
don't think we should think that it's
it's an easy problem to solve it isn't
just about numbers it isn't just about
money there's a whole lot of different
effects and there's a lot of push coming
from the countries in which these people
are coming which I touched on just now
but I think my own sense was that the
government did want to help and there
was a very powerful understanding
between President Nicolas Sarkozy when
he was interior minister with with Mr
blanket when he was the British interior
Ministry they really did try and come to
terms
together to find ways of stopping this
this horrible and dangerous and illegal
human trafficking
um well
I'm you that you were the uh ambassador
to France I think you probably worked
under two prime ministers obviously
David Cameron I'm guessing the other one
would have been Gordon Brown or perhaps
Tony Blair
um is there anything that the present
prime minister could learn from the way
that those Prime Ministers negotiated
with the French
well as it happens that all three of
those people you mentioned were Prime
Ministers when I was an ambassador in
France
I regretted personally that there was a
bit too much Point scoring if you like
at the expense of of French and other
European neighbors during the last year
or so
um probably affected by the politics of
brexit and trying to show that it was
working and also blaming other people
for some of the problems we had with the
implementation what I'm really pleased
about to see now is first of all it
actually is trust had a very good
meeting with President macro when she
went to that European political
gathering in Prague and clearly now
James cleverly has a good relationship
with Catherine Colonna his opposite
number who used to be the French
Ambassador here in London and there's
good progress being made between the
interior ministers so I think that the
chemistry is looking a lot better now
and my advice in so far as anybody
wanted it is you know never forget the
importance of the personal relationship
the basic courtesy is staying in touch
understanding where the other ones are
coming from and what they are doing and
seeing what you can do together rather
than publicly seek to score points I
don't think that achieves anything yeah
am I right in saying that you were
previously the deputy private secretary
to the then Prince of Wales
yes okay I was okay it's his birthday
today of course how important are
birthdays
um to him and what sort of memories do
you have of him
well I think he's 1948 so this he must
be 74 today
um you know on his birthday we sometimes
didn't find a modest way of of
celebrating the occasion uh it was never
a huge deal I thought for him it was
just
um another day when he would go about
his duty perhaps see a few friends
privately he always appreciated the odd
little message of either support or
congratulations or tiny gift and so we
certainly knew this was who were in the
household but the birthday was coming up
but he didn't make a big deal of it and
I suspect that like the rest of us it's
more a question of Odio one more year
has gone now
um rather than something to celebrate
oh I know how you feel I'm dreading
turning 40. thanks very much all right
you don't need to laugh so much to Peter
thanks very much indeed for joining us
much appreciated thank you
uh let's find out what uh the home
secretary's been saying this morning
we need to
um significantly reduce the numbers of
people crossing the channel the Prime
Minister has been absolutely clear I've
been absolutely clear the legal
migration particularly in the numbers
that we've been seeing more recently is
totally unacceptable what's important is
that in order to solve the problem of
illegal migration on the channel we take
a
multi-dimensional approach there's no
single answer there's no quick fix
there's no silver bullets our
Corporation and collaboration with the
French on the channel on the UK
Coastline on the French coastline is
absolutely integral to ensuring that
there is a a robust barrier preventing
people disembarking from the French
beaches in the first place
hmm at mayor of London's decal just
listening to that so with us that clip
from the Home Secretary who's literally
just arrived from Paris thoughts good
morning good morning well listen I mean
if you forget if you're a migrant
Landing in this country if you're a
martian land in this country you
wouldn't believe we've had a Tory
government for the last 12 years look I
I see every day as the mayor London the
the benefits of migration to our city
and our country the issue is uh you've
got to make sure there is a safe way for
those who have fleeing persecution
Asylum Seekers and refugees to come here
otherwise uh they are driven into the
hands of criminal gangsters and they pay
at literally thousands of pounds and
risk their lives to come here so what
the government's got to do is have a
humane way for people to come here
lawfully in a way that they can process
their uh claims but at the same time
have proper Collegiate working with not
just France countries in the EU
countries in North Africa and it's
really important to realize that you
need to both have a Humane immigration
policy but also to make sure you control
the borders yeah but what about those
economic migrants who are coming just
because they want a cushy alive in the
UK well listen uh last year we had 40
000 up until November trying to come
across the English Channel 40
000. so clearly the actions of Bravo and
Patel here's the point many of those who
were coming maybe fleeing persecution or
Asylum Seekers there is no other way
right if you're fleeing persecution to
make a claim to uh the UK so if there
was a proper system set up you could
make sure people could apply in a safe
way but also you could make sure by
working closely with with France by the
way president macron has been in
position for some time we've had a
conservative prime minister for 12 years
there's no reason why this dog deal
couldn't be done uh you know over the
last six years since we left the
European Union the same goes by the way
with other countries in the EU the same
goes with those countries in North
Africa of course we've got to be dealing
that source with the issue of people uh
you know leaving the coast in a
dangerous uh dinghy but it's combination
of a safe way for people to have their
claims processed but also are clearly
working with those Source what did you
make of the immigration Minister Robert
generic used to be the housing minister
of course uh housing secretary who who
said that people were coming here uh for
one of the reasons is that the hotels
are quite nice that they get to stay in
well I've not been to some hotels that
Robert generic has been to what I do
know is having seen and heard
some of the stories from those at
manston I think nobody would you know
try and come out to stay at Madison but
we can't escape the fact that if you're
fleeing for your life if you're an
asylum Seeker if you're a refugee in
amongst you there may be people who are
coming here for other reasons economic
migrants to improve their quality of
lives and so forth but we conflate
Asylum Seekers refugees students family
reunion those on work visas economic
migrants that's why it's really
important to be careful and understand
the differences between these different
forms of migration you're worried about
londoners and those that are renting and
how much it's costing them I'm really
concerned we have 2.6 million londoners
who live in private rented accommodation
they face a number of challenges that
all of us face cost to live in energy
Bills going up the government
potentially increases tax in taxes this
Thursday in the Autumn Budget on top of
that renters in London pay on average 2
500 pounds per month in the last year
alone rents have increased by the
greatest amount since records began by
more than 16 and we're publishing some
research today which shows that four out
of ten of those renting four out of ten
are worried over the next six months
they won't be able to pay their rent
which could mean they've been made
homeless so we're lobbying the
government in London just like labor
colleagues and others Lobby the Scottish
government to freeze rents for this
short period of time just to allow those
families to stay in their homes during
this cost of living crisis what about
those people who you know not
necessarily fact have who are owning
these properties and are renting them
out to try to make ends meet themselves
so forty percent forty percent more than
40 of those landlords who run on the
properties own them outright there's no
mortgage at all and for those that do
have a more we've always saying to the
government is for a short period of time
uh you can be supporting these families
because the choice is at the cost of you
know the choice of staying in your home
uh because you're you've had your rent
Frozen or landlord making a bit less uh
profit and by the way there's a
president for this our government to
give them credit as a consequence of our
lobbying during the pandemic uh did uh
pause all evictions uh for those tenants
live in their homes but also have a
mortgage holiday to those people who
needed a mortgage a holiday so it's
possible to both support these families
who are struggling to make ends uh meet
and also those small minority of
landlords who may uh you know have
difficulty Square in the circle because
of the mortgage payments and the rent
not going up to to do so here but here's
a problem rents go up by 16 as they have
over the last year is far in excess of
interest rates uh or cost of living
that's why it's so important to support
these families
um I've got a friend who's recently
joined the Police Service met
um and it seems every other day she's
being called out to a stabbing what are
you going to do about her well firstly
thank you your friend for joining the
police service we are recruiting in in
London uh we now have more than 34 000
officers which is the most we've had in
recent times because of our investment
from City Hall and without being in any
way complacent about the issue of uh
stabbings and knife Crown we have a buck
the national Trend in London so in
London unlike the rest of the country
we've seen knife crime going down knife
crime with injury going no enough gun
crime of course not enough I'm not
complacent so both as a member of
Parliament and as uh mayor I meet brief
families I also meet victims of crime
one homicide is one too many in this
year alone uh the first 11 months we've
managed to reduce by almost 70 the
amount of teenage on the size because of
being tough on crime supporting the
police but also tough on the complex
causes of crime supporting young people
Youth Work youth workers giving them
after school clubs clubs at the weekends
uh clearly not enough I'm particularly
concerned about register you know knife
crime but violence against women and
girls so we're supporting women's groups
but also tackling perpetrators as well
How concerned are you about potentially
um Mr Corbin trying to take your job off
you well listen I've got I've got the
best job in the world I'm surprised I'm
not surprised uh that the newspapers are
reporting uh that other people want the
job listen uh one of the reasons I
wanted to be the mayor was to give back
to this city that's given so much to me
and my family I won't be surprised if
other people also expressed an interest
true or not in relation to being a mate
and that's fine that's the joys of a
democracy right people can put their
names forward and run for the best uh
jobs and I'm looking forward to the
election which will be in May
2024 and I'm I'll be asking londoners to
lend me their trust in their vote again
um what do you make of the suggestions
that um and apparently we have checked
it out and it is the case that um those
in the higher echelons of the labor
party uh do not want him to be able to
stand there's a labor MP ever again I
certainly don't know about that no but
I'm asking well look I mean you know in
my view uh one of the things that care
has done really well kirst armor is to
address serious concerns around
anti-semitism I I think that one of the
reasons why my style is Jeremy corbyn
was had the whip removed was he's
failing to accept the report and failure
to apologize uh you know clearly if
Jeremy corbyn does apologize I suspect
the whip will be uh restored the lower
part is you know a big tent but there's
no place in our tent for anybody who
gives the impression of condonian
anti-Semitism do you think he is Auntie
semi no I don't it's not I work with
Jeremy over many many uh years uh he's
not just not a racist he's an
anti-racist but you can't escape the
feelings of Jewish people who feel that
some of the things that went on when
Jeremy corbyn was a leader did condone
anti-Semitism and there were examples I
experienced it of anti-semitic remarks
made by layer party members uh they most
of them if not all of them have been
kicked out they should be kicked out we
aren't just a party that isn't
anti-semitic we should be actively
anti-racist driving out antisemism from
from our party and from society and I
think it's really important that we show
that moral leadership but also that
sense of solidarity and there should be
no space for that in our party
um it's always great
for joining us on the program thank you
we've been talking about what's
happening haven't we as far as the Home
Secretary is concerned she's in uh
France this morning Paris to be precise
and we're going to be hearing more from
her very shortly in Daily a deal that's
costing something like 70 odd million
pounds we're giving it to the French in
order to try to stop people uh risking
their lives basically coming across the
channel to try to find a better life
here in the UK so we'll have more on
that coming up in just a few moments
time before that though let me tell you
that the um
the king is 704 today I wonder if I
could just sit down again please Laura
thanks very much uh the king is um 74
today
um and Rob jobson's here to talk about
it hi ants good to see you 74 does he
still celebrate
he's going to celebrate privately today
I should imagine having a martini at the
end of the day but yeah he's looking
good isn't he happy birthday your
majesty indeed so
um it was the first time I think I'm
right in saying that he uh while he's
been King that he's he's been at the
senator for yesterday how do you think
that would have gone done for him
well it would be an emotional I think
because it was the first time of course
his King he's laying his weave not on
behalf of his mother but as as king
um but it was pretty seamless I think
for everybody else I think that because
the queen had had the foresight to to to
to to allow him to sort of lay that Reef
on behalf of her over the last couple of
years I think that sort of just made the
whole transition well it seem as this
used to be the most one of the most
important engagements she used to carry
out and he was doing on her behalf
before okay and his son was there too
but not the other one
yeah the Prince of Wales was there
William and he laid The Reef um on on
behalf of himself but no William I
always find it strange that we are
paying tribute to the to the the war
dead and those who have fallen and and
the only two guys that have served on
the front line the Duke York and Prince
uh Harry the chickas for whatever
reasons are not there
um but that is the way it is yeah
um how worried do you think Charles will
be or anxious uh about this book that's
coming out and I mean the title is not
particularly Charming is it
well I think a lot of the things that
Harry's been doing aren't particularly
Charming in the last year or so but like
it's not going to be easy it's coming
from the inside directly from the inside
we won't have a book as big as this
since Morton's kind of a true story
which was from the inside so whenever he
said he's going to have to take
ownership of it it's going to be even if
there's a subtle criticism which it
clearly is because we saw that in the
Oprah interview the way he was talking
about his father it's not going to go
down too well but my feeling is actually
I think that um that since the the
Charles has become king there's a lot
more empathy with him the role of King
is so different to me in the heir to the
throne you know we all have a bit of
ownership in that there they are the
king is part of our
um is part of the national identity so
if you start criticizing your king
you're criticizing the country as well
and I don't think that's going to go
down too well for Harry I think you know
it would be different if if the queen
was still alive she's not and I think
it's a big mistake that is going forward
with it and um you mentioned Andrew Duke
of York
um he wanted to come back into her
Frontline service didn't he for the firm
that's not going to happen no that's not
going to happen I mean this there's a
lot a lot of arguments on this side we
all saw that appalling interview that he
gave and you know frankly if he hadn't
given that I think we might be in a
different situation we've seen the
dershowitz ruling with um Virginia which
basically just the whole thing fell
apart in in law I think if the Duke of
York could continue with his um his
legal fire if he was allowed to do so
which I don't think he really was
because of the Jubilee coming up uh we
may have had a different outcome but
there's no way now that you can come
back now yeah and what about the crown
Before I Let You Go yeah I always watch
it look it's as I say all the time it's
drama and it's quite good drama the
other thing is there's good actors in it
which I've you know we've seen some
award-winning actors in there and as
long as you remember it's drama it's
it's okay we don't sit there and go I'm
sure that if uh you know someone from
the court of Elizabeth the first was
around saying I can't stand that film
that while an Oscar you know that they
never got it the fact is it is drama we
shouldn't get too head up about it I'm
sure the crowd love it every time
there's a row in the media because it's
even more publicity uh we know that um
that Charles liked Diana Ross and he
also was uh quite keen on the Spy skills
do you think he likes Taylor Swift
I think he's is he more like a Leonard
Cohen sort of guy I think I think he
probably is actually but thanks very
much Anita for joining us thanks a lot
because Taylor the reason we're talking
about Taylor Swift is uh because she
dominated the MTV Europe Music Awards
last night scooping four Awards
including best artist
You Gotta Wear a lot of sequins
um and learn choreography and that is
very hard
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you MTV thank you she's
very pleased um she thanked her Legion
of fans known as swiftis as she accepted
each award other winners including Nicki
Minaj Muse and gorillas the
international Music Awards which took
place in Dusseldorf was hosted by
celebrity power couple Rita Ora and taka
watiti
um looks absolutely fantastic doesn't it
I did actually ask the um
foreign secretary whether or not he was
a keen on Taylor Swift he said he's been
known to belt out
um we're never getting back together on
the karaoke machine there you go uh
photobombers often a reporter's worst
nightmare but this one might get off
lightly take a look at this and provide
a home
[Laughter]
and can you generally filming your story
when an elephant tried its very best to
put him off he was trying to tell us
about how often the elephants are being
taken care of amid the worst drought
experienced in Kenya for more than 40
years when this elephant friend tried to
lighten the mood instead we absolutely
love that yep that's our favorite
picture of of the day so far very latest
from what's happening in Paris in just a
few moments time our own home secretary
is there as we speak hammering out a
deal with the French we should know more
about it in three or four minutes time
we do believe it's costing at least 70
perhaps up to 80 million pounds and it
will involve British security Personnel
probably border force uh in control
rooms uh on the other coast and vice
versa also wanted to go on patrol with
uh with French excuse me with French
police but apparently that has been
ruled out more on that it's coming up in
just a moment do stay tuned our way
[Music]